We saw this example in the previous video where we had to give this bench
a unique
identity. To give it a unique identity we
needed three things a reference point a
horizontal line and a vertical line let's see how we
actually use those three things
let this be  Our reference point we draw a
horizontal line from this reference point then we
draw a vertical line which will be
perpendicular to this horizontal
line we will need some numbers to denote the
columns so we mark 1 2 3 4 and so on in
equal intervals similarly
on  On the vertical line we mark 1 2 3
4 with the same interval length as we had on the
horizontal
line There is no limit on the numbers we can
mark on the horizontal and the vertical
lines so we mark these arrows at the end of
the lines most  Important The Reference Point
Will Be The Number Row
Now If We Have Any Point In The Region We Can Easily Give It
An Identity Based On The
Numbers We Have
Marked But Wait What If The Point Is Here How Would
You Give It An
Identity It's Simple We  Just extend this
line to the left and this line down in
words Let's zoom out a bit and
modify this diagram slightly We draw the horizontal line like this
Notice that it has arrows on both its ends
The vertical line is drawn like this again
with arrows at both  It
ends we extended the horizontal line to
the left and the vertical line down words now
no matter where you place the point on the
plane you will be able to give it a unique
identity we can't keep calling those lines
horizontal and vertical every time so  We
name them we
generally call them the horizontal line
as it is also referred to as the horizontal
axis and the
X
Similarly we call the vertical line y What we
call the vertical axis and the va axis
The
Exes We'll Cover That in Another
[Music]
Video